Five minutes, Melo
Understood
Ser Oakley
Carmelo...
seems you’re my last friend in Knicks colors
Quite the opposite, actually
The whole city cheers your name
outside these Garden walls
I saw what they did to you
More like what I did to them
It’s not right
You’re a legend
I’m just an old enforcer
When I saw how the front office was treating you...
well...
I did what I’ve always done...
I stand up for our best players
’Specially against the twonks
who run this house these days
Well I’m here to return the favor
Now c’mon, we don’t have much time
Whaddya mean?
Whaddya doin’?
We’re getting you out of here
Wait...who’s “we”?
(Whistle)
Derrick! The key!
Toss it now!
Huh?
Joakim?
Where’s Derrick?
He had to go
He had family issues
What?
Well do you have the key?
Uh huh, yeah...
Well then toss it!
Right, right. Okay, sure
Oh crap
Men!
Do you hear that?
It’s game time!
YEAH!
It’s early, for sure,
but if the season ended today,
we’d barely be in the eighth seed
Do you want to be in the eighth seed?
No!
Aye!
No, Thad, we don’t want that
Ayyyyyye DON’T want the eighth seed
I don’t want that...
We are the Pacers of Indiana!
We don’t settle for the eighth seed
No!
Would Ser Reggie Miller have settled for the eighth seed?
Would Jermaine of Neal have settled for the eighth seed?
No!
Probably not!
Would...
M-Mark Jackson or...
Rik Smits have settled for the eighth seed?
Maybe?
Who is Rip Smith?
We are not an eighth seed team!
Better than that!
We will not be a seventh seed team!
Well, we probably will be though
What I see, is MUCH better than our record
I see a...
fifth or sixth seed team!
Probably seventh
Who will at BEST make it to the second round
FIRST!
But probably no further!
YEAH
I’M OKAY WITH THAT!
Right now,
our defense is 25th in the league
Let's get that up to 15th!
Yeah!
And our offense...it’s 20th!
Boo!
Let's inch that up to maybe also 15!
15!
So let’s go out there
and send those Pistons back to Detroit
and fulfill our destiny!
To have a decent regular season
and a forgettable playoffs!
YEAH!